[Music]
manuel is with us in san antonio hey
manuel how are you
i'm doing good dave and yourself better
than i deserve how can we help
excellent okay here's the scenario my
daughter
who's going to graduate later on this
month from high school she has the
opportunity to attend either one of two
universities
university a for 88 000 total
and university b for a total of two
hundred and eight thousand
she wants to go of course to university
b
how do we explain and or convince her
that university a is the better option
okay what is she studying
she wants to study uh to become either
biology or chemistry major and then
pursue a medical degree
okay
um
do either one of these you have any
actual data that more people get into
med school
from either one of these universities
it's about the same
you have actual data or that's a guess
no no we looked at the we looked at the
acceptance rates into medical schools
from both of these universities
so her attending the more expensive does
not help her get into med school
it doesn't increase the probability now
okay what's her reasoning for going to
the more expensive school
it's away from home
there it is
there's the underlying issue
so how far away from
it
so the first thing i would say to her is
um okay if you're going to be a medical
doctor you have to use critical thinking
skills
okay right and so basically what we're
saying is is these two schools have the
same acceptance rate
and so you are not paying a dime more
to go
to the uh to to for education
your only reasoning is you want to spend
an extra 140
dollars or whatever this comes at 100
over a hundred thousand dollars you want
to spend an extra hundred thousand
dollars to live away from home
good point
yeah and so that that's uh
so
this is not about a discussion about
education this is a discussion of do i
am i willing to pay for
you to live away from home
yeah not am i willing to pay for
you know if you went out on your own and
just weren't going to school and you
graduated from college high school and
went got a job
uh and went out on your own
uh i'm not paying for that
that's like your job because you're like
being an adult and stuff right
right and so if there's an if there's
another good reason i mean we can
discuss it i don't mind
asking a series of questions
uh i assume you're paying for this
yes we are paying for this okay how much
money do you have saved up
well we have enough saved up for the
first the
for university a at 88 000
but we don't we do not have enough saved
up to go the extra 120 000 to the 208
000. yeah so you can cash flow
university a yes okay yes yes yes the
answer is yes but not cash flow
university b
there have to be other options there
okay
well there's yet another reason um i
don't want you guys i don't want you in
student loan debt
exactly
does she have any skin in the game here
it feels like she has no concept of how
much money this actually is at 18.
um
initially i thought she had the concept
but recently
after our discussion uh
i don't think she does because
it
um she insists on wanting to go to
university b
and it's like well we can't afford it
and it's like
that just caused a shutdown in the
conversation
well we can't afford it but also i think
we just need to talk through the
reasoning of what's going on here okay
right um i i love you and i want what's
best for you
hey i don't want you in debt
because it's not best for you b i want
you to be able to live your dream i'm
not trying to tell you to not live your
dream in terms of going to med school
but there's no difference between these
two i'm going to med school
and um
[Music]
and so really all we're paying for is
for you to live away from home and we
don't have the money for that
and so honey i'm just sorry as i can be
it's just a horrible it's a horrible
thing to be you you know you're going to
get your college paid for but not the
one you wanted to go to
and you're not going to get to move away
from home in order to do that and so
unless you figure out a way to pay for
it if you figure out a way to pay for it
and by the way if you paying for it is
you taking out student loans
i'm not going to give you the 88 000.
i'm not going to subsidize your
stupidity
oh good point that i didn't even think
about it to approach it from that
perspective yeah and so i you know and
at the end of the day i love you i've
got your best interest at heart i have a
hundred thousand dollars almost laying
here to help you do this to live your
dream and i'm willing to put all of that
towards you because you're my daughter i
love you more than life itself but i'm
not going to participate in things that
bring you that don't bring you good
results
now if the other school had a an
acceptance rate that was 5x
school b did of school a right then i'm
going to start scratching around trying
to find scholarships i'm gonna have her
work an extra job i'm gonna have uh you
work in an extra job and you know if we
can get her into med school five x times
um
you know five times more likely then we
can talk about trying to make that
happen but so far i don't hear any value
for school b in what you've presented to
us
other than she gets to live away from
home whoopty doopty
yeah
now from
for more information she is a really
smart cookie and she's got i would hope
she is if she's trying to get into med
school
exactly and she's gotten tons of
scholarships and that's why these
numbers are quote unquote as low as they
are
but yeah they're still
this is post this is net of scholarships
yes yeah exactly
wow exactly so
um
it's incredible what she's accomplished
but these are very these are both
expensive schools then
yes sir they are yeah yeah but again
we're willing to go with
school a because we got the cash flow
for it can't go to school b
like you said we're not going to fund
her to
live away from home yeah
and honey if you'll go out the driveway
you will notice that there aren't two
bentleys sitting there
because your mom and i can't afford them
right no
and you'll notice your mom does not you
will notice your mom does not have a 400
000 diamond on her hand
because we can't afford it
right
and so you know money is finite we're
not in congress
good point sir you know and so i mean
this is just a values lesson
and um
you know but i think underneath all of
this and i would really hesitate to play
the card but underneath all of this at
the end of the day is
um
i i love you so much that i'm just gonna
make you do what's smart for you because
it's my money
okay and you know i'm i really wouldn't
say that if i could possibly avoid it
instead i would try to reason i would
try to persuade i would ask questions i
would talk it through get her to come to
the conclusion i'm really just paying to
live away from home because that's
really the net net of what we're talking
about here and uh we want you to live
this dream but if you live your dream in
an improper way it becomes a nightmare
yeah okay i'm not going to any more than
i'm going to let you spend this money on
cocaine i'm also not going to let you
spend this money on something else that
brings you harm
right
and reminder that med school is still on
the horizon which is a whole another
beast to tackle financially yeah yeah
exactly financially there's another
beast that we're going gonna have to
tackle together four years down the road
and so we gotta have a long-term vision
here we have to have a long-term game
plan and part of this is an immaturity
going i just want to live away from home
well that's not worth 120 thousand
dollars i'm sorry yeah yeah i'll tell
you what uh hang on i'm gonna have kelly
pick up we're gonna give you a promo
code i think we've got them for the
borrowed future documentary do we okay
or we can get you one i think if not and
you guys watch that together with her
you your wife and her watch that
watch the documentary it will blow her
mind and yours
it's all about the epic failure of the
student loan crisis there's a dock in
there that's almost a million dollars in
debt
and orthodontist in the department
and he's crying it'll make you cry when
you watch it
it's unbelievable
yeah borrowed future just won um number
one webby yeah long form documentary
very cool